that's right Star Wars was not the only
movie to get a trailer dropped yesterday
we got a trailer for the movie that I
don't know about the circles you run in
but my friends have been looking forward
to this trailer for years
this is trailer 2 the warcraft movie now
if you're down with world of warcraft
you're like I wanna know everything
that's going on in this movie not
necessarily okay we're going Warcraft
prime on this one i watch this trailer
and I saw all the potential in the world
right in front of me I was like anything
could happen with this you look at this
story the story looks fascinating just
imagine a political story of conflict
between two kingdoms two races that hate
each other
ultimately the key to survival is
working together and not everyone wants
to do that now create hostility just
imagine this is humans and orcs what is
I guess this movie's gonna concentrate
equal parts on the humans and the orcs
and that is where I see all the
potential in the world plus the director
Duncan Jones did did moon source code
and Warcraft right he hasn't done a lot
but the movies he's done they're really
good just one of those things I can't
help but be like Duncan Jones is doing
kind of a political movie of two
kingdoms it happens to be in the
Warcraft world I can't get excited for
that [ __ ] / CGI has gonna be a [ __ ] ton
of CGI because it's a Warcraft movie I
noticed that at Comic Con at Comic Con I
saw the armor and the swords and the
shields I was like oh the armor for the
human super exaggerated like it is in
the game I like that they kept the
stylistic look of the armors it just
feels like a Warcraft movie if they
didn't do that it'd just be another
medieval looking movie it just does arm
be the Lord of the Rings ripoff really
the most important thing you can take
away from this trailer is that thrall is
baby Moses that's what we know now but
then there's the flipside it's like
every movie based on a video game that
has come before it has not been great
greatest ones more of a combat that's
just it's a fun movie I'm not gonna sit
there and be like Christ move arrow he's
talking about the best just like on my
top 10 of all time Warcraft is a
different thing entirely I feel like
with war crack you can't just be a good
video game movie and what Warcraft to be
a movie that is just one of the best
movies that year I just hope they don't
rely too much on fanservice as we've
learned from movies in the past you can
have all the fanservice in the world if
you don't have a solid movie it's just a
[ __ ] movie with a lot of fanservice
I'm surprises as all we have gotten
there hasn't been a trailer for this
movie yet and this movie was supposed to
come out next
month they got pushed back because Star
Wars got pushed back I didn't want to
compete with Star Wars so they were like
fine we'll come out a half a year later
but it still was in production it was
still being made so they had footage for
a trailer long ago probably a year ago
surprises all we've gotten granted I'm
glad they didn't spoil his story in the
trailer or anything like that I mean I'd
rather a vague trailer that shows us the
pretties really all I know is humans and
orcs and they hate each other but they
have to work together that's what I knew
before going into this so I'm like all
right on the credentials of the lore and
the director taking on the story it's
either gonna be a great movie or it's
gonna be shrek 5 I feel like the next
trailer they give is gonna let me drop
my armor but for right now I'm like to
be good everything I like about this is
the interaction and the conflict among
the ranks of the orcs and among the
ranks of the humans the political [ __ ]
that's what I like all the stuff I'm
like okay Stella pretty pretty cgi in
the cinematography I'm like I've seen it
I hope they have a good movie in here
and I hope they don't rely too much on
the pretty pretty but I'm more
interested to hear what you guys think
about the Warcraft movie so the Warcraft
movie the trailer have you seen the
trailer what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see where is he
mounting while running you can't do that
that's it [ __ ] it I'm out